our next guest is called the bite
administration's immigration plan
recruit and release joining us now
arkansas senator tom cotton
senator welcome back good to be on with
you chris
you just watched my interview with
secretary marcus your reaction sir
chris it's rich that secretary mayorkus
won't let press travel with him to the
border but he will come on your sunday
morning show
and peddle the same kind of nonsense
that has created the biden border crisis
in the first place i mean he's basically
saying the united states will not secure
our border
and that is a big welcome sign to
migrants from across the world
so you say that you have three simple
solutions
what are they yeah chris the
uh by administration keeps saying that
trump somehow dismantled
the immigration system that's false it
was the bi-administration that
dismantled three highly effective
policies
first the public health exclusionary
order they lifted
that order as it relates to minors well
guess what we have now at the border
lots more miners that's not a surprise
second
the remain in mexico policy the trump
administration worked with
the government of mexico to allow
migrants who showed up on our border
to make an asylum claim but remain in
mexico while we adjudicated that rather
than just releasing them into the
country
and third the so-called safe third
country agreement with countries like
guatemala
that says if you pass through a country
that's not your own
seeking asylum you have to make that
asylum claim in the first country you
pass through that's the international
norm
that's what we should do joe biden could
reimpose
all three of those things this week if
he wanted to
uh one of the things i was struck by at
the end of the interview secretary
mallorca said
quote the border is secure the border is
closed
is it uh no chris of course not the
border is wide open
there are reports now that customs and
border patrol may be
directed simply start processing people
in the country without even giving them
a notice to appear
in court and of course all of these
bogus asylum claims
are taking up so much manpower and
resources at the border that means that
we also have
other threats like increases in fentanyl
and other kinds of drug trafficking
or persons on the terrorist watch list
across the entire border
the border right now is wide open
because the biden administration
dismantled
the very effective policies of the trump
administration and the agreements we had
with mexico and other latin american
countries
i want to turn to another subject
senator you voted against the
1.9 trillion dollar coveted relief
package and i want to put up some of the
things
that it would do for arkansas it would
provide stimulus payments of up to
fourteen hundred dollars
to ninety three percent of adults in
your state
and ninety four percent of children in
your state it would also provide
1.2 billion dollars for schools in
arkansas
grades k through 12. senator are you
saying that the people of your state
don't need that money
well chris that bill would do a lot of
other things as well you know we've been
talking about what caused this border
crisis look at a couple other provisions
in that bill
for instance they're going to stimulus
checks to illegal aliens as well or
money to sanctuary cities
those are the kinds of incentives that
help migrants come to our border
more broadly though chris we worked
together last year with the democrats
and the trump administration
to pass multiple bills to help the
american people
get through this pandemic many of those
bills passed unanimously we
did one in december as well the
conditions of course have
changed now vaccines are spreading
across the country
case rates are declining rapidly
republicans had no problem
providing more money for vaccine
distribution for instance or
to help people who have lost income but
we shouldn't be spending two trillion
dollars on a lot of
unrelated democratic priorities or
sending out money to families who
haven't lost any income
that's what this bill did
uh here is one of your other complaints
about the
the covid relief bill take a look sir
look how crazy some of the democratic
ideas are i mean they had a chance on
saturday morning to stop
checks from going to prisoners from
going to the boston bomber for instance
and on that vote they declined every
single democrat
wanted to continue the practice of
sending checks to prisoners
but senator under two previous coveted
relief bills that you supported and
voted for and that president trump
signed
prisoners also got checks in those bills
well chris that was obviously congress
never congress's intent the trump
administration irs and treasury
department
did not send checks to prisoners liberal
advocacy groups sued to try to force
that a liberal judge said they had to
last month was the for this month was
the first time we ever had a simple up
or down vote on whether those checks
should go to prisoners
and the simple fact is that every
democrat voted to keep sending checks to
prisoners
i don't think that's a smart idea i
suspect most americans don't either
one of the next big pieces of
legislation that
president biden is working on is going
to be an even bigger
2 trillion 3 trillion 4 trillion dollar
infrastructure plan and i want to look
at some of the infrastructure needs
that arkansas has 4.9 percent of the
bridges in arkansas are
structurally deficient 193 dams have
high hazard potential drinking water
needs in your state 7.4
billion dollars president biden
wants to pay for this plan at least in
part by raising taxes
on people making more than four hundred
thousand dollars a year
and to raise the corporate tax rate from
twenty one percent
up to twenty eight percent would you
support i mean aren't the
needs in arkansas sufficiently urgent
that you could support taxing people
making more than four hundred thousand
dollars in raising
uh the tax rate on corporations which is
still lower than when which
would still be lower than when president
trump came into office
to pay for that chris we have
infrastructure needs in arkansas like
every state does but
i suspect based on what i've heard from
my democratic friends in the senate that
this bill is not going to be geared
towards those needs it's going to be
geared towards big tax increases and
implementing something like the
green new deal now if you think your gas
bills have gone up a lot recently wait
till you see what you pay at the pump
after the democrats do that
we can do this kind of bill though chris
without big tax hikes the reason we're
talking about an infrastructure bill
right now
is that the last bill we passed is about
to expire into this year and we passed
that bill in 2015
with more than 80 votes in the united
states senate without tax increases
because we focused on a lot of the
problems we have with infrastructure in
this country
like excessively burdensome and lengthy
and uh
cumbersome permitting and regulatory and
environmental approval processes
chris you probably know that the
pentagon was built in 16 months in the
1940s
it took the government years to repair a
bridge in front of the pentagon that
just runs a couple hundred feet
the problems that we have in this
country is not that we don't have enough
money for infrastructure that it costs
too much
and we spend too much on things that are
not roads and bridges
and broadband access right finally i've
got about a minute left here sir
uh president biden talked this week
about
trying to reform not and but to reform
the filibuster so that
senators have to keep talking around the
clock
in order to continue the filibuster and
to stop the legislation take a look at
president biden i don't think you have
to eliminate the filibuster
you have to do it what it used to be
when i first got to the senate
and you had to stand up and command the
floor once you stopped talking you lost
that and someone could move in and say
i moved the question of
there has been an explosion in
filibusters
357 cloture motions to end debate many
of them not successful but 357
between 1975 and 1992 since 1993
one thousand eight hundred and three
cloture motions and as i say many of
them didn't end the filibuster they were
just attempts to
uh senator you know at some point maybe
as soon as two years from now you
republicans are going to be back in the
majority
isn't there something to be said for
more legislating
and less gridlock
no no chris there's something to be said
for compromise and bipartisanship
and respect for the rights of the
minority in the senate
these rules have been in place since the
beginning of our republic and these
democrats are engaged in pretty highly
situational ethics you know just four
years ago
27 democrats still in the senate wrote a
letter urging
mitch mcconnell and chuck schumer to
maintain these rules now most of those
senators have flip-flopped simply
because they have
the barest of majorities republicans
refused to change those rules four years
ago because
we respect these traditions in the
senate and we know
they've helped forge durable bipartisan
consensus
legislation senator cotton thank you
thanks for coming in today always good
to talk with you
thank you chris